le remplacement des gardiens d'immeuble
devient des problèmes les plus
difficiles à résoudre pendant le mois
d'août
en ile de france ils sont 90 milles et
pratiquement la moitié d'entre eux part
en vacances en même temps et pour les
remplacer aucune formule miracle n'a pu
encore être trouvé
l'enquète à ce propos de dominique
rotival lorsqu'intervient pas vos
vacances il a deux solutions soit il
applique la convention de 1966 c'est à
dire tune désigne lui-même son
remplaçant et qu'il le paye lui même
grâce à son mois d'août généralement les
gardiens du nommé s'arrangent entre eux
deuxième solution le gardien a dit que
la convention de 1980 dans ce cas de
figure c'est le syndic qui vêle
directement le remplaçant mais le
gardien doit accepter que ce dernier
soit logé dans ses meubles
une solution qui vous vous en doutez est
loin de faire l'unanimité l'année
prochaine la convention collective votée
le 16 mai dernier sera parfaitement au
point donc totalement applicable
conséquence les gardiens devront
accepter que le remplaçant utilisent
leur logement même s'il s'agit d'un
connu et les vacances des gardiens
dépendent aussi de leur statut si un
gardien appartient à la catégorie à
c'est à dire si on n'a que des activités
limitée du type distribution du courrier
l'arrangement est facile mais s'il
appartient à la catégorie b c'est à dire
s'il a une présence quasi permanente
le choix du remplaçant est plus délicat
ainsi certains gardiens préfèrent partir
en septembre parce qu'on utilise trop de
travail notamment avec le courrier
c'est le cas de marcel jeanne il est
gardien depuis quatre ans dans le 20e
arrondissement et s'occupe d'environ 70
logements
la seule solution c'est un couple de
retraités qui y gagnent ou remplacer
parce que c'est pas possible nous sommes
en catégorie exceptionnelle il faut être
là
même pendant les week-ends en sécurité
la convention qui a été signée récemment
ne vous semble pas une c'est fait c'est
fait disons
par un technocrate qui marche encore
avec l'esprit de 1930 pour aller
deuxième aspect important du
remplacement pendant les vacances la
sécurité marcel et jeanne effectue
régulièrement des rouleaux surveillance
dans les caves et dans les parkings le
jour comme la nuit
la sécurité est ici fondamentale puisque
l'immeuble comprend cinq baux
commerciaux
d'autre part le mois d'août est celui où
il ya le plus de cambriolages commis
dans les grandes villes
le fait que bon nombre de concierge ne
soit pas remplacé à part entière et sans
doute l'un des facteurs qui augmentent
le nombre de vols les gens sont moins
habitués des remplaçants son voile à
lutter aux allées et venues alors ça
peut permettre certaines intrusions
d'autre part quand c'est un emplacement
risque d'un côté à l'autre de la rue les
anciennes catégories de gains de
concierge automatiquement
on se demande toujours pourquoi par
exemple dans la rue pelleport on a eu 19
remplacer cambriolé pendant que les
remplaçants était partie déjeuner le
problème du remplacement pendant des
vacances rejoint celui du week end pour
les gardiens qui sont astreints à une
présence permanente
ils ont la possibilité de récupérer
leurs congés mais encore une fois la
loge ne doit pas rester vide
en réalité c'est une profession en
pleine évolution où il est de plus en
plus difficile de définir les tâches les
devoirs de chacun
la concierge de papa cible favorite des
humoristes est une espèce en voie de
disparition
quant au gardien de grands ensembles
ceux qui ont 200 logements à charge ils
exercent presque un autre métier